- welcome to the h3 podcast thank you to
ring for sponsoring us quickly want to
announce the new teddy fresh collection
is out sorry to do this in front of you
Tricia I know here we are we're live on
Teddy fresh calm and you struck more
about that later today's gas way didn't
I get honey brush where's you here yep
I love okay I actually love I didn't
know it was a brand for real people wear
it and I thought it was just a cool
thing and then I realized it was your
brand and I was like no way
mmm but you love it Victor beforehand
because I think we'll make it through
this we'll see well first of all Trisha
Paytas is here too are we here squash
the beef or roast the beef
ooh I wouldn't I would love to squash it
but I like you guys talking about me so
it's actually can I just say like I
actually genuinely hated you at the
beginning of this year in May like I
genuinely when he won yeah like
genuinely just liked you and thought you
were like disgusting okay and then Shane
I was like how could you have gone on
their podcast and he's a troll I was
like oh I didn't know you were like a
troll I don't think I'm a troll I think
you're a tribe I think you're a troll no
are you no you're a troll I'm sure
you're just like how like what it means
is that you say things you don't mean
for attention no not anymore I used two
years ago I used to and you think I do
that now yes No so okay all right angry
I believe you are angry but like for
example how is it that your life is so
dramatic
it just is it always has been my life is
dramatic so so it's like every week
there's a new revelation in your life
that you announce on your kitchen floor
thank you then you stir up a lot of
sation about it but it's like clockwork
I mean it's just a little too uh any
dramas this year except for you brands
the trance thing is that drama my gender
is drama like that's just who I am but I
don't think that's the best drawing you
what why because I don't look male as
that I'm being so serious like why would
I go on like my whole audience is LGBTQ
right they all come in why would I like
try to offend them or mock them like
that doesn't make any sense so okay let
me just kill my career is that I like
that would make you didn't kill your
career you how would you kill your
career your whole career is built on
this kind of engine of of driving views
okay let's let's talk about that because
I got a lot of emails from trans people
who do you want to talk about this ready
should we just get in whatever yeah I'm
here I was gonna I was gonna ease into
it
you called me worst in Donald Trump and
you said ela should leave me did you do
you believe those things I did at the
time yes I still think it was too good
for you like looking at her now you look
like a model like in person like I
thought you're pretty on camera but in
person you're like tall and thin and
like gorgeous and then I even like baby
like I here's the thing like what kind
of man would be appropriate for you
though oh my goodness I think like a
like a Dennis Quaid type or like like a
even like a Zac Efron like I think like
that if you like fish my turn I think
that would be you think Howard Stern is
uh appropriate for you uh cuz he gets
the personality so you don't go for
looks obviously but like you must like
personality and Howard Stern has the
personality he is more personality the
fatter personality you have a
personality yeah but it's not as good
it's not that because so when you so
when you say I'm a troll what do you
mean because the way what I define troll
has is someone and I don't mean to be
provocative but I do think of you as a
troll because I see that you are at the
center of a lot of dramas that drives
views to your channel that I'm times
question if you do believe that that or
for example when you respond to my
videos I don't necessarily believe that
yours angry as you're upset as you are
leading on
believe in your videos I was as angry
the last video I did so I've done how
many response I've done like three or
four responses to you guys the first one
I even did a really angry response a
really nasty response to like our first
beef in May or whatever I was this but
you know why I was like don't post it
because I was already in so much on the
internet my just don't post it I was
pissed these last couple times I kind of
just like responded because I was the
thumbnail on clickbait which I was so
excited about that's what I thought but
but to see you don't you don't say that
in the video you were you what the
vinkle of your videos h3 h3 is
slut-shaming me i watch i watch you're
not really though i do watch you didn't
know about the Gatsby you didn't know
about but you asked me why that what's
why do we have a mobility scooter what
the the thing was okay yeah sure okay so
but what do you mean when you call me a
troll because I don't think I'm a troll
because you'd you say stop for attention
that video for instance the one
Instagram versus reality you did to be a
troll like obviously the girls you were
making fun of nakita Tana like we're
obviously not unattractive women you
were doing it to be a troll and calling
Tana a beached whale quote I believe I
said think II know I that I said but I
believe what I never called anyone beats
well I said it looks like she just
washed up out of the ocean so were you
saying she was a beautiful mermaid no
you were saying she was a beached whale
like she well or or or a well sure or I
mean you said I look like a corpse and
look at oh yeah yeah you did yeah that's
what do you do when you guys well but
but again so you caught what is so what
does it mean when you call me a troll I
know you were trolling specifically too
because if you were doing some like
educational informational like you know
let me like rally people up for this
like get people high my message you
would have used pictures of me are the
same day I get what you were saying cuz
I agree which is why one of the
side-by-sides use I posted myself on
Instagram me with makeup we without but
the thing was you were taking like awful
angles from different days you like
that's not the same person it was like
it was makeup in different day so like
it was a troll like obviously you were
trolling because you didn't did you
believe that well what I believed
is that people can look very different
themselves on social media as one way I
then you know and and in certain other
situations not look like that at all
and why is it that you think people
really responded to by the way after
getting to know you I don't think you're
guilty you are very forthcoming with
like the two different ways you can look
so so I do give you credit for that okay
thank you but I do think also I know I
just think I think though that video had
actually a really powerful message for
me personally and I have heard other
people too
if you look on Instagram today a lot of
people will look a certain way and you
just take it for you just think that's
what they actually look like right and
then one day when he showed me all this
stuff I realized whoa like wait I'm
crazy I had no idea and that's why I
myself decide by sitting all the time
the one of Mila Corpse wasn't my
side-by-side it was me in bed like just
from an awful angle just and then me
from like Hawaii the week before cuz I
loved the message too because I'm always
like okay I don't look like this all the
time you look strong with I think but I
think where you lose something about our
channel is that Ethan is also like just
trying to make it silly and not just
this isn't just a serious message to
show at your class you know it's also
supposed to be a funny video and is just
goofing and this is the reality and be
funny about it use yourself as an
example what you do you always want
unflattering pictures and I think it's
funny to say she she was she what I mean
from that angle she was really shoved
into that but you never call yourself a
Twinkie or a fat piece of [ __ ] oh I say
women I'm just saying
and one picture she was super I think
probably photoshopped look of course
okay thanks she was shoved into a yellow
bikini and she looked like a Twinkie
it's funny I can't take that chance
because one you're a male so you cannot
like period like that's just like the
only women can fetch him can women fat
shame men no no no one should fashion
you anywhere you can fashion without a
knife in your skin to shame me
you can't know you can't skinny shame
people either like no and I do what can
I do about you can talk about things
that are you so like okay only I can
only talk about me excuse me
hmm all design your chubby guy so you
should make fun of a chubby guy I'm a
chubby girl I can make fun I have a song
called fat chicks I could make fun of
like fat girls cuz I'm a fat girl you're
a Jewish man fan and think that I'm a
religious acetic do you are you mad in
Israel how you can't get more acidic
than that right Hasidic Jews are you're
just you're Jewish shaming us right now
you said you're obsessed with Jews and
that's made me nervous
no I got I got in trouble years ago
because people think I find a shy Jewish
people cuz I love Jewish man shouldn't
say I'm obsessed this is what is okay
okay does that mean look that's what it
looks like you're Jewish aiming me that
they're super Orthodox no they're super
religious why would you say that about
me all dressed in black robes in black I
know when I see the Knights
cheeseburgers you can't do that really
you eat cheese verse yeah of course how
do you but you're Jewish but you don't
identify as Jewish or you do yeah if I
Jewish you can be Jewish but you don't
have to be Orthodox you as fast during
the Ossining holidays no oh that's like
not Jewish man you guys are like Maddie
okay we're you love I got Israel all the
times I wanna find a Jewish man but they
won't date like any Jewish guy I like
[ __ ] they can't marry me they tell me
straight up the bath like I can't marry
you you're not Jewish I'm like I think
they may just be saying that as an
excuse no Jewish people can't marry
non-jews you have to convert
[Music]
sorry to break that deal Jews are very
flexible I don't think so you always
have to convert his wife convert very
flexible of all the Jewish I think that
I should be able to say that Anna looks
like a twink you can't you cannot I did
and I support like to do that feel like
you can loosen up you just made a lot of
assumptions about Jewish people and I'm
not offended I couldn't care I couldn't
care less if she wants to be that good
in a bikini she needs to work out I knew
an assumption which I'm now educated for
so if you were trying to educate people
by doing their I made to get offended
now like that's so annoying
I was making jokes whatever I start
making jokes about Jewish people jokes
about Jews you know what I mean I'm not
making jokes about I was like genuinely
questioning so bow your Jenny when they
question something that's one thing but
you are like making jokes I was making
jokes at Jewish people's expenses if I
was like okay you killed Jesus you know
what I mean like that's how you say it
it's the way I said it out that's not a
joke you just said something that's
offensive
me saying she looks like a Twinkie is
funny because she's not the point how
are you to decide what's funny maybe
people think that's hilarious a lot of
people thought it was funny and it looks
like a Twinkies of fact no Jewish people
killed Jesus as a fact is what I'm
saying that's debatable but it no it's a
fact but he definitely hotly debated and
I think that only people like Mel Gibson
actually believed that first of all wait
no we're gonna beat it Jesus was a Jew
it's not like a bad thing I'm not saying
that it's like the Jews killed Jesus
that's not that's like propaganda that's
all the Romans killed the Roman
government killed Jesus I'm okay well
anyway you like to think the Jews I
understand by the way no no I do not
support that I don't say Eddie Lestrade
you look you this I'm saying like I
can't make Jewish jokes as I'm not
Jewish
just like you're not if you were no if I
was a fat chick I could call tan a
Twinkie you could more so because people
would think it's funny because you're
also that she looks like a Twinkie how
could somebody
but then it's because like you identify
I don't know if I said this publicly but
identify as a woman so that I am a fury
now you're offending the trans community
why I'm serious why you've never said
that right now well I'm coming I just
I'm a fan I am a fat chick we're a
lesbian couple and I'll have you know
that she's you see she thinks my
personality's charming the only I never
got to respond to that no actually yeah
I think Ethan is the perfect match for
me I think you can do better but if
you're happy that is way too bad that's
why we're married Hey look at her and
her personality I look at you and your
personality and I'm not judging but I'm
like judging you know what I mean I'm
kind of like oh like you with some
language that guy
I just find him interesting gray type
someone who can dominate you and be a
man you know what I mean what you wait
you're making weird gender roles because
you're not no I thought I'd nominate you
as a woman yeah because of what you are
is not fully a man right you're coming
for women on the Internet you come from
I'm a fast
yes holiday and I am all days of is Tess
holiday is a beached whale you can't I'm
a fat chick you're not a chance you're a
guy you can't make fun of anyone I'm not
your race not your religion okay so you
say you're a man you identify as a man
why are you dressed as a female it's
like my character it's my job it's like
it's like a drag queen like man dresses
drag because I appreciate your man in
drag that's how I look at it it's like
my job right like my I I've shown my
boobs but you always looked like that
yeah because I've always done that I've
been a stripper since I was 15 years old
like how did you see that trans people
have are attended variously where do you
feel like you're a man and we're always
inside like always in my heart like I've
always been when I don't want the
attention like when I go out on
something I always I've always
belt mail from a very young age like
it's not about like not wanting to play
with Barbies are wanting to only be with
guys and stuff like that it's not like
that at all it's more of just the energy
I feel like I get uncomfortable when
people like obviously it's my job so now
I'm like oh yeah I talk about my tits
all you want but I've always been
uncomfortable if people like talked
about like me as a female refer to me as
her like all that sound like that it was
always my comfort even as a kid I
remember not wanting to go in like the
girls bathroom and there's no way to
explain it or to describe it as someone
who hasn't felt it like I just
why do you it seems that people who are
trans have what's called gender
dysmorphia just for you such an [ __ ]
sorry
and and they attempt to transition to
the opposite gender because that's how
they see themselves not all transgender
that's just on the doctor as in gender
is not sexuality it's not sexual it's
not what you're assigned with that birth
that's not gender or your gender isn't
what's in your pants just like the penis
doesn't mean you're a male but the fact
that you're trans male it makes me think
that you would want to identify you
would want to look more like a male no
no I like the aesthetic of a woman but
so what so tell me what what makes a
male what is it that makes you male like
what does that mean it's just it's just
your energy and how you feel inside I've
never been a woman I've never thought of
myself as a woman I would be like who
are you attracted to gay men homosexual
men I dated gay men yeah and do you
think what would a gay man seeing you
I've dated a gay man for a year and a
half but like so what does he get out of
dating you because you don't look like a
female and you don't have a penis of
presumably it's male it's just the male
energy like you're attracted to a male
energy just like I'm attracted to I've
been attracted to transgender
male-to-female transgender female to
male I'm attracted to everything but I
haven't been with straight women it's
not that I'm not tractor to them I just
haven't been with straight women and so
when you have when you have relations
with a gay man what does that look like
um it kind of depends I've had a few
relationships and it kind of just
depends a lot of like it can be it can
be pegging for sure but also like we've
had like that when you say when you say
pegging that means you're strapping on
and then going it to that it give me a
strap-on or it could be anything what
like what else anything any phallic
object easy
I've shoved up like cucumbers up
people's buds I've had candlesticks
shoved up mine it's just what I
candlesticks yeah okay the holder is not
the actual you told me in the deems when
I asked you if you wanted to move ping
that you've eaten you've already moved
think rotten [ __ ] so you're done eating
yeah
when and you sent that to a message see
you yeah okay when I'm on Twitter
sometimes I'm a little drunk by myself
and alone so I think I just kind of say
things okay like what have you made
thing bran pizza [ __ ] yeah yeah I'm not
a fan of eating out but I will what's
wrong [ __ ] washed okay that's not
rotting but it's just not a wash it's
fine and some religions people don't
wash their vaginas like they're not
allowed to for until Saturdays or
something like that I don't want anyone
it's another religion of a girl that I
know and she can't wash till Saturdays
and that's just her specific release
just her I think she just I'm not
educated enough on religions you know
before we move off the trans thing I do
I got an email from a fan who has
identified as a trans okay and I want to
read some comments that they offered
okay
so here's here's the first part tricia
mentions no feelings of gender dysphoria
which is the medical condition that
identifies someone who is chants gender
if she were to go to a gender identity
therapist and asked to medically
transition she would most likely be
denied because she has no gender
dysphoria right well I wouldn't say I
don't have dysphoria I hate having a
vagina for sure but as far as like
getting a dick I mean a [ __ ] is an
inverted dick basically you know what I
mean it's not it's not we have a penis
just like you it's just little I have a
video from 2015 called like I have a
one-inch penis like I've always
identified as having a penis I do a [ __ ]
as a penis so that's I feel like that's
man enough I don't need to have my full
eight inches or whatever so I think I
mean I have a penis
okay so then she goes on to say she also
mentions a weird fixation with gay men
and the past she has been obsessed with
gay men which many find weird this
doesn't make her transgender either it
just means she is fetishizing
homosexuals like a weirdo no I'm dating
men
are into men like but year but so I how
but she's right how is that not just FET
having a weird obsession with gay men
what does I have to do with being trans
cuz I am a male like I guess if I was a
female that like identified as female I
was like yeah this is my [ __ ] and don't
[ __ ] me in the ass and all the [ __ ] like
that like yeah but my stimulation comes
from the pee spot not my it's not a G so
you're a trans male but you're also
you're trans homosexual male yes but I'm
into I've dated straight guys I've dated
gay women I've dated transgender women
I've hated transgender men I you know
I've done it all mm-hmm so I'm not I'm
not I've never dated straight females
and I think they're more not I want to
say judgmental it's fine if you're not
into what I am but they a lot of
straight females want penetration from
an actual elongated penis my just tucked
in yeah I can see that being an issue
although that I see that okay let's not
get semantics oh let me say her
explanation of being transgender is
wildly incorrect and she should not be
considered a representative of the
transgender community at all oh she
continues it hurts me to see Trisha
talking about choosing your gender when
you cannot in fact choose it your
genders with you since birth it cannot
be switched or changed the reason
transgender people are transgender is
because their gender doesn't match their
sex if I could change my gender to
female to match my female sex organs I
would do it in a heartbeat because I
would no longer have gender dysphoria
right well one first and foremost I
don't want to be a transgender
representative at all because and that's
why that was my issue with going on
anything talking about it cuz that's not
even doing that video the reason I did
that video is because I met someone at
one of my shows in Toronto who was male
to female and he looked like a boy he
had he didn't wear skirts you don't wear
makeup nothing because he well one he
couldn't afford it but he's like I can't
afford to even wear a denim skirt but
I'm still a female and I was like that's
so weird cuz that's exactly how I felt
too so I shared my story just thinking
like oh I'm just gonna cuz everyone goes
no shows like you help me you help me
something I'm going to share my story
and that even I respect it 100% I get
with that person saying I totally get it
I'm not trying to like convince anyone
but on the flip side of that I've gotten
so many messages of like I feel the
exact same way of male to female female
to male who were like haven't fully
transitioned but they feel female
because when I was just on the doctor's
like I said the doctor on the show said
like when your
in the womb there's all these
chromosomes actually like floating
around like in fact you could be male
like it could hit you like it could be
male and you come out genetically female
so you are you don't care about looking
like a male I don't know I don't care
about it I think maybe later on in life
right now this is kind of my thing it's
how I make money it's like so for me I
don't care about looking like a male
I like the aesthetic of a woman like
I've always thought that even like naked
if I go to a strip club I'd rather see a
female stripper than like a male
stripper I just like the aesthetic but
if I want to [ __ ] someone I'm it's
usually like I want to be either like
[ __ ] in the ass or like what the male
like but I will I will totally like be
with females - that's what I'm saying
you gender sexuality or not you prefer
to be [ __ ] in ass as of lately I was
always scared of it cuz I thought it was
I thought it was like a a gay thing to
do you know what I mean and then like
lately I realized that's what you are
that's where I get ya that's where I get
the stimulation and I just recently
found out that I was like oh I actually
get more stimulated through you know
what do you I don't know thing easy I
don't know I don't I well it seems
completely unrelated to the to the gay
thing
Yeah right but there's I just wonder
what's the point of all these labels
because it's like if I can get this
straight you're a you're so you identify
as a man you're you're a drag queen so
that means you can dress like a female
but you're also a gay man which means
you can have sex with dudes but it seems
like in a weird roundabout way you're
just trying to justify it that you're a
female you are actually a female
suggests affiant no just to explain how
you have sex with guys and you look like
a female like you're just a female with
a strong personality it's hard to
explain no I just I don't like being
referred to as like female but I get
that's what I look like and I get that's
what my thing has been I guess it's hard
it's hard to understand it's a very much
a territory right I'd yeah I just don't
feel comfortable with being a female
versus should we really say he said I
preferred you as my guest is he he is a
youtuber that's fine I think for me it's
like but it's not confusing to the
audience they're like wait what I
like this look like good when Courtney
Cox got married Dave our cat she was
Courtney Cox our cat right so you could
like you could switch it but a lot of
people when they get married they keep
their name you know they don't get they
don't change their name Jennifer Aniston
was never Jennifer Pitts she Jennifer
Hanson cuz that's what she's known as so
for me I was been known as she all this
time for 13 years on YouTube and I'm
like okay to change it now but I
actually call me him that's totally fine
if people prefer that but like for me
it's not to me that's not a big deal
like you said I don't I don't think
labels is a big deal and even my
coming-out wasn't a big deal because me
being a male should be a big deal a lot
of people it is a big deal because they
unlike you are uncomfortable with the
way they look so if if it was me for
example I would want to look like male
and to make that transition it's very
hard and you get a lot of judgment so
you are lucky that you're okay with your
looks but they are not and then for you
to come out and say I'm transgender it
kind of like cheapens dare struggle but
why cuz it's mice it's me it's I'm not
talking about anyone else this is my
story in my journey it might be probably
I've had my whole life and it's awful
so let's feel like you don't have a
problem with being referred to as she
right and you don't have a problem with
how you look so you don't have very many
issues I've had many many many male
gender we're talking because you said
that you're okay with your look you you
don't care about looking like I'm not
okay with it I'm not I'm not ready to
change because this is how I make money
like my I get made fun of all the time
you've seen you talked about it my tits
my vagina everyone roasts me and Twitter
like it's one of those things I'm not
okay with it but it's how I make money
so I put it out it doesn't feel good to
hear that about my vagina and how my
tits and [ __ ] being [ __ ] up it is
that's dead fern know what I'm saying if
you're happy I'm not I'm not I know I
love that I'm not saying that though
that's different I don't like how I look
that's different okay I'm talking about
you being okay with looking like a
female
wanting to look like a male that's not
what I'm saying that like my job YouTube
patreon all that stuff is me looking
like a female do I love it no do I want
to look like a male no I don't know I
don't know what that what that entails
in the future so for most transgender
people it's a lot more crucial fight
throughout their lives than this
Caitlin was 60 when she transitioned
into the female aesthetic so her whole
life she's invalid to be a female just
because she looked like Bruce Jenner
like it's not to say that is kind of
ridiculous like I should transition when
I first came when she came out she also
transitioned to female at 60 so maybe at
60 I will but it's I'm just explaining
to you why the video that you made has
such a backlash because but it's my
story I'm not saying hey if you're
transgender like you should be
uncomfortable you know what I mean I get
it there's a lot of transgender people
who are not uncomfortable with a just
body there's it's almost like you're
this you just kind of like taking the
easy way out and kind of being
transgender because it's cool it's
definitely not because if anybody dates
me like let's say let's say I'm a
straight female and I only want to date
guys if they look up and see that I'm
transgender do you know how many men are
turned off by that so many men even
asked me to this day when I go out with
them like you're sure you're not a man I
sure you weren't born a man like that's
so gross there's so many [ __ ] I'm
like that's just the reality of it you
are a man - yeah yeah that I wasn't born
with the penis is what the thing because
they get that there's so many try but
they saw your vagina and they saw ask
you that
no I'm saying beforehand like when we're
on dates because my point is a lot of
people are transphobic me coming out
transgender is not gonna help my dating
life it's not gonna why why would I put
that on myself to her I'm trying today
I'm trying to get married why would I
put that out there just so people can
look up that I'm a transgender if I
truly don't believe that for I don't
mean you don't make money YouTube does
not monetize transgender videos like I'm
not let me put a pin in this it's been
30 minutes already I'm gonna go to a
quick commercial break we're gonna
continue on hold that thought we're
gonna pick up right where we left off
after this quick quick quick quick
commercial break
ring the device that has changed
security around the world rings mission
is to make the neighborhood safer you
might already know about their smart
video doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or surprise visitor you'll get
an alert and you'll be able to see hear
and speak to them all from your phone
that's thanks to the HD video and
two-way audio features on ring devices
now listen here around my home I have
ring spotlights I have a ring doorbell I
have the whole ring of security and it
makes such a difference you guys I sleep
so much more soundly knowing that if
anyone approaches the house I get a
motion detection if I see any Shannon's
going on I can boss them with the siren
I could yell at them I could say hey get
out of here I'll just know before it
happens and here's the best part that I
don't even think they mentioned in their
copy it gets saved to the cloud
immediately so no matter what happens if
you got some slick willies from home
alone some slick would they call
themselves in holon this let the slimy
bandits or whatever trying to cut and
it's what sticky bandits are trying to
cut your power some shenanigans it's
gonna be zipped up to the cloud before
they even gets a cut clip the dang wire
your impregnable as a listener you have
a special offer on a ring starter kit
available right now with a video
doorbell and motion activated floodlight
cam the starter kit has everything you
need to build a ring of security around
your home just go to ring.com slash HD
that's ring.com slash h3
thank you to you ela for not only just
being beautiful and talented and an
excellent co-host but also an incredible
designer the mother of teddy fresh who
just came out with a new collection yet
again another slam dunk look at this
three-way panel primary colors it's hot
it's fire it's super hot fire now look
at this Chanel and brighter pullover
supa hot fire and purple black but you
got it let me show you a close-up of the
patch because you really have to see it
to see how cool it is bear with me look
at that it's chenille like a teddy bear
give me a break bro it's embroidered the
black one is really cool too I mean the
black ones amazing look at this go ahead
and do me a favor and forget about it
now you might think I'm going on and on
about teddy fresh but I need to give us
time to run to the bathroom anyway
frankly you don't have a choice you need
to do this but this is cool stuff I
think you'll be interested to watch this
so we've got the long-sleeve shirts
these this this I'm excited about you
know long-sleeve color-block why not
we're figured people love long sleeves I
certainly do and now we've got all your
favorite color-block colors and long
sleeves Eva Klein original now this
shirt EAL is wearing it right now
this shirt is amazing it's got a
high-density print so the outline of the
Sun and the text is a high density print
so it's kind of like a 3d print it's
very cool we stand up and show kind of
the all over it move the Teddy first
thing because it's covering yeah me oh
can I sleep yet go ahead show the back
so they could see it's like all over
yeah this is a technical master shot was
a collaboration between my husband oh I
thank you it was his idea well you you
know you took it all to fruition you'd
make it all happen but I guess the
concept was that I want I drew a son and
said can I sleep yet that was it and he
loaded everything else but the and then
on the sleeve teddy fresh by you a
client this is the limited edition by
Eli Klein t-shirt it's insane it's epic
you got to love it you have to love it
we got the three-way panel now this is
the long-awaited or of
washer and spearmint we're calling this
one and and pink and this is just some
original art by a very talented artist
we work with and I just couldn't be
happier with the with the design and the
quality of the print we captured really
the essence of the high quality of
artwork that we got on the shirt we've
got some new teddy fresh classic shirts
logo shirts and pink and and teal
we've got a corduroy backpack in three
colors black red and green crossbody bag
fanny pack a wallet never before made a
wallet before it's all in corduroy and
it's all available right now at Teddy
fresh dot-com welcome back we are here
with Trisha Paytas we have we are in the
process of I would say roasting the beef
BBQ we're gonna work through this issue
and then we've got a pizza on the way
we're gonna move bangs we're gonna dip
the pizza in a ranch dressing which is
something I've done previously and I
want to ask you questions about moving
because I frankly don't understand let's
continue on you've stated your
admiration for Andy Kaufman do you see
yourself as a Kaufman ask type of
actress actor I think I'd be like
disrespectful to him to say that but I I
would like to if I could emulate anyone
who'd be Andy Kaufman because Andy
Kaufman to quote something that you've
said about him is that you never know if
it's the real Andy Kaufman or not
and you've said I like to think that
people never know if it's the real
Trisha right yeah so so what bearing
that in mind how is it that how can we
take you seriously when you say you're
trans mail or anything else for that
matter you've just announced that you're
getting married today this morning but
it's like wow okay so so how do we not
know that you're just the you know the
center of your own reality
the thing is is like with the ending
Kauffman to like yeah I mean he would he
would do stuff and troll people on stuff
like that but at the end of the day he
has also a real person so when he
announced he had cancer no one believed
him but it's like it's not like he went
out to prove to people like hey I've got
cancer you know what I mean it's just
like one of those things where it's like
I put out my truths and I also put out
me like for entertainment and sound like
that obviously something like a serious
issue like transgender and how it could
affect my life and like finding a
husband or wife or whatever like
obviously would be to me it's just so
stupid that people think that would be
at all I get it I understand it I
totally get it it's not like whatever
but I mean I can't just constantly like
this is real this is not like you know
I'm gonna do YouTube you know a lot of
people think your guys's relationship
isn't real you know what I mean I don't
even think you're actually married
we're actually siblings that's what I
people don't actually think Loki can I
can I say I feel like you're related in
some way but you guys don't know what
have you ever done like 23 I'm 95 I'm
like 99% European Jew and yo has like
she's like all African she's like
African Jill
are you Arab she's out that's not
African where do you think the Middle
East is it's in Europe iris and Asia
actually I'm wrong no but you're from
Morocco and you're from Morocco Libya
and Turkey okay well here's the thing
but your YouTube people think you quit
YouTube because it was I'm on YouTube
right no no I mean like incest um that's
what I've heard that's what I read and
like like a reddit post okay is there
any truth to that because you guys avoid
scandal whatever you have it's an incest
show a stress reduction is everyone no
friends tell me what a strange reasons
for just our initials that's not
everybody watching this knows that
apparently using your fan I question
that you guys aren't you troll neutral
as well how do we know you're married
how do we know anything how do we even
know and knows anything
yeah no one knows anything I don't think
we should go down there right let me ask
you this is it true that you've also
identified as black chicken nugget and
lesbian those were trolls
well not the lesbian one but them
obviously so how can you be both how can
you be a lesbian and a gay man you can
be a lesbian a gay man how well at the
time like okay here's the thing
both all those videos were made I was
used to be really into drugs I did a lot
of like meth and stuff like that so when
I did those videos I was high for sure
obviously I don't think I'm
african-american but I made that video
with sunglasses on for a reason
obviously I was a chick it like the
chicken nugget era that was that was my
truth at the time the chicken you were a
chicken nugget that was your truth at
the time because I was [ __ ] up okay I
mean that was like Special K [ __ ] you
know what I mean like that was like you
were deep into but in your mind you were
goofing around obviously didn't you
think you were chicken nugget I know
what what did you say okay and that's
how I was doing okay
which is a lot of like that's a green I
think right yeah I was doing that and I
was awesome it's a mix and then I tried
meth for the first time this year when I
was when you did my videos when I had my
that day you posted it was my birthday
and when I ended up in like the hospital
for a meth overdose so that was when you
so I can't I literally was coming down
straight from the hospital like blood
all over my face like wiped off and I
saw the video and I was like I'm
responding right now so in my head I
feel I've been I haven't done drugs
since May but I drink but I don't do
drugs but um and in my head at the time
I thought I'm gonna respond this is like
I was like pissed about it you know what
I mean so same thing was checking out
getting the black sing with lesbian at
the time those were my truths in my head
so okay but I was sober when I meet the
transgender video I'm sober now so okay
I've been haven't done drugs with me and
I mean well is that something that's
ongoing in your life yeah no I had a bad
drug addiction from like 19 to like 22
then I was clean for like five years and
then I like just did it occasionally but
yeah I'm not really that person and then
this year I kind of got back on the
wagon through somebody I know and yeah
but I did a lot of pills like a lot of
like pain pills and stuff for my a my
thing so that's been my whole life is
just pills which I don't I can't even
take them like if I have surgery now I
don't even like I had just I tore my
meniscus in September and I had like I
didn't take any pain pills for it I was
just like I don't wanna do that so I was
definitely high and like [ __ ] up and
stuff when I did those videos well I'm
glad you're sober now yeah I feel I
sense that you're in some ways trying to
put the responsibility on me for your
drug the drug problem you know
no no no no I was having that we kept
saying I was I smoked meth the day you
made the video it just happened to be
the day you made the video it was my
birthday and I didn't see the video
until my birthday night so that was May
8th and I didn't see the video till May
9th is when I made the response because
I didn't actually see it yeah it just it
just happened to be that day I was doing
meth a bunch of times before that
between the February 5th and like
February fed is when I went to mental
hospitals 5150 to February 5th of this
year and then I went to the mental
hospital and then I still was using
through February through May and May 8th
was the last day and if anything I could
have credit you to my sobriety because
that's my well I'm glad you're sober I
mean congratulations May I was in some a
that's a long time I'm very happy to
hear that now over 5 months right yeah I
I'm very happy to hear that and I hope
you continue the sobriety I love Jewish
men they have like a sensitive side to
them at the end of the day they're like
[ __ ] but that's really ok all Jews
that I know are total do their ass no
you are you're a dick but then okay well
here I go back to being a dick only do
by the way she's obsessed with and
doesn't know the difference between
needs and Jews my last wafer was only
half Jewish he told me he was a Jew he
kept saying how much you I'm a Jew and
then he was half Jewish like um sized
without the skin what is that yes yeah
here's without the skin and do you
prefer that is that your preference yes
well no no no I like a skin now I used
to be against it but not his game and
like the skin that's more sensitivity
okay thank you glad we got that out of
the way the trans video has over 3
million views many people are claiming
that you do that in part for YouTube
revenue is that true no cuz YouTube
doesn't monetize like lgbtq+ videos like
if you talk about it they don't put it
they don't put ads on it also ID
monetize any of my scandal videos my my
first h3 my response to you guys was
team on it or I I didn't monetize I was
indeed monetize I am on has all my vlog
squad videos those are all not monetize
I showed it on Instagram I don't
monetize it I went to your channel
yesterday and that video gave me two
free mid rolls two of them yeah you know
but YouTube does that I can I literally
can show you I can screenshot it and
show you like it'll say like even on my
d monetize there's ones I do not
monetize myself like any ones I've made
YouTube will put their own ads on there
I guess and I don't know no I swear I
know how YouTube works it doesn't work
like I can show you I literally I mean
oh you're getting paid for that I'm not
I could show you I haven't made I can
show him analytic I know YouTube that's
wrong I'm telling you I'm not gonna let
you know unless it's claimed by someone
there was no wonder there's no content
it was just perfect example is like my
music videos like Lizzie McGuire yes
this video was not claimed there's no
third party content ads even on my own
the ones about the blog so I don't put
ads and I showed it I literally showed
it on my Instagram with your analytics
computer I literally don't have any you
have it on your phone no I don't you do
every youtuber has it on their phone I
swear to god I'm not I'm sorry I'm not
buying this I've been around I know the
game you have ads on this video just
technology you have to mid roll I don't
know how right now it ad no I believe
you I see it with the I swear it's not
monetize like it's just not my Adam and
Eve ones are not monetized by ads still
go up there because they can't get I
can't get monetizing the ads so go up
there so I I don't know what else to say
I would straight-up tell you when I need
stuff for money I say it's for money
like you're making I'm just saying you
are definitely making my own you are I
know how you to work what's the app
called what's the happening download
YouTube creator studio you don't know
you don't it uses your YouTube
credentials my YouTube credentials yes
just on my phone on your phone okay
what's a called
YouTube creator studio go ahead creator
like I can even show you I don't even
have this look I don't even have a
downloaded like I told you I never had a
download download it will go fast
so no you don't to show your face so
lady so uh if you are in fact making
money on that video does it change any
of the claims of people no because you
you were even on the doctors on
television saying oh I don't even make
money from that video what you do I'm
gonna show you I don't I make no money
off essence why do you think I do
patreon and show my [ __ ] I make no well
it supplements your income obviously but
no video has to so I okay now what do I
do
I says get started login okay now go to
that video
how do I do you do it okay okay I'm not
trying to expose anything that's private
but it's all demonic I hold on hold on
hold on where is it
apology and then it's coming up
regarding imagine I am transgender 3
million views green icon monetized and
I'm gonna tell you exactly how much
money wait you have to cut that cuz
YouTube will literally go away my
monetization you can't say how much you
made that's also of urban legend really
yeah video that's crazy see or the right
no I didn't know no I swear really why
would I I swear on my life
II know that you've made eight thousand
dollars for this video how do you feel I
mean if I was about look can I show you
my other ones there I literally don't
monetize it like everyone I don't care
about your other videos I just care
about this one we're not television it
said SD monetized we got there what it's
like obviously like okay look all these
will see you saying do you monetize but
even like the David Ober yeah cuz the
camera can see
so what I'll come around the look but I
don't want the cameras here analytics oh
well this is just do you see I'm saying
like I marked it myself as not monetize
but now it's showing up the yellow thing
like that but the thing is is like I
don't monetize these so if there's an ad
if there's an ad on these look here's
the thing
I don't mind it it's my job I would say
like okay yeah I mean I can make my
office
it's my story but I agree with that but
you've been going around saying tiered
in your defense and I was into that I
don't make money from this I swear
why would I do it so I just think that
it kind of undermines that whole
argument that you're doing this out of
the just to tell your story but clearly
you you made 8,000 bucks from it yeah
but are you sure I'm not gonna get like
I talked about I promise
money do you make a month on a th3 not
the podcast with the video your main
channel say it so I don't get to
monetize to how much you mean I don't
want to say it publicly but I'll say I
promise how much you made I'm the video
like your last video tell me how much
you made right now $2,000 look it up
Casey yet I showed you mine let me see
yours
it's only fair no I how much I made that
I wasn't making money from it you were
and I said you got ads and so you open
that that's fine but you're saying it's
an urban legend yeah if you talk about
my money so you talk about your money so
that way let me say on the last podcast
how much you made you don't have to let
me just the end share and that's only
fair well we know we do have a you're
not gonna get the monetized I guarantee
that's our urban life and no they don't
and I've asked them about it yeah it's
an urban legend are you nervous are you
just nervous are you just nervous
because I showed that you made money
from that video show it that's my I edit
out like how much I made just like say
that that's not you can say she made a
lot of money if you can just edit out
because they will they do I know what
happens it doesn't I know the BP of
YouTube on my text I'll text him and ask
and a few responses okay well I don't
care you can expose me all you want
about that like I don't give a [ __ ]
about that but go ahead
no you I promise you there's nothing
about I've read the Terms of Service
I've axed to my partner's because people
always thought that from the beginning
of time from very early stage of YouTube
and
happen till they talk about how man oh I
promise you're not gonna get in trouble
I swear to god it's not the Terms of
Service
how much money
there's tons of youtubers who go that
show their analytics and their channels
are I did I just screamed it out it's
not even necessarily true it is true by
the way it was 8,000 but if you go on
YouTube and look at youtubers showing
their analytics their channels are up oh
my god if my whole channel gets the
monetize I'm doing well by the way you
can sue me if your channel gets D
monetized so I as I can see you for my
income for the next you want have to sue
me I'll give you money you I feel like
you don't have any money I'm really like
when you sue people like you can't sue
people have no money because then they
don't think oh girl
yeah cool I'm broke I mean it's fine I
don't judge there's no judgement I I
don't judge it
I'm just saying I can't sue people I
have no money because then they don't
pay you I've done it I tried to do it
before I guess you're [ __ ] then can I
show here can I show my earnings in a
video not show can you tell how much you
made on a video well I'm being as we did
more show I'm being even more extreme
how do you the contact of the because
because I'm connected and that's a let
me that's impressive I have to say if
you have them you really do I don't have
any contact at YouTube here you might
you do watch it like I promised you I
would I would not jeopardize I promise
you I'm done this myself I've looked
into this I'm like I'm obsessed with all
these details I promise you you're fine
but I senses I don't know if you're
worried about that I've not or that no I
don't like that's fine like are that
you're actually worried about your
channel being doing no I'm actually you
know because like it's my I doesn't
wanna get to mine I that worked out over
13 years I don't I understand no I just
looked at your phone and shouted it out
like how could they hold that against
you because I don't know anyways it
doesn't matter cuz they could look
verify that that's how much always it is
a matter cause okay like
[ __ ] like I truly thought it was I
wouldn't bring it up and be like let me
show ya you know like if I thought it
was actually my eyes yeah let me just
show like I don't know that's pretty
good I mean good job that's good revenue
offered me to like write a book okay
sure I'll write a book like take the
cheddar cheese I'm not ashamed or like
me yeah or like make it honey excellent
so good we got past that let's see is
the pizza here damn now we're gonna eat
after that do a second do you want do
you have anything you want to say to me
after all this we've talked about the
trans how do you feel as your opinion
about me or really changed at all during
this conversation
yes tell me okay good is the worst I
just say that you're kind of just the
worst I think you know you wait hold on
so you hate it here you came in liking
me more but now you hate me yes I saw
you guys when I first came in and I
wasn't even expecting guys to like greet
me I thought I was like they always do
this like a locum hop they just have you
like jump in they don't really talk to
you about it which is fine I don't care
what I get I like you before the podcast
no that's stupid but I know I know
you're really nice and sweet yes we are
don't don't
loop her in with you because you're not
like I said we are nice and sweet you
are what did I you are whatever so what
have I done exactly that was nice now
that I'm like in person with you I can
100% say you are the word you called me
nasty you talked about my [ __ ] but see
now that I'm in person you haven't said
any of that troll which is fine but also
you're kind of just the worst okay what
do you mean by because of like how he
called you out on this that's fine no
that's not no you I called you Nass when
did I call you nasty let's talk about it
I don't know one of the videos because
oh because even though you talked about
for 30 years that's I do think that's
nasty that you tweeted me a picture
you're jelly you can talk about my
genitals for 30 I didn't know what I'm
making jokes about it but you can't make
jokes about something yes I know you can
you I did okay
joke's on my [ __ ] then I can show you my
clip because you're talking about it for
30 minutes on a podcast you can you did
and I thought it was gross
he said nasty nasty I also said gross
that well then you're just the worst you
can't talk about a woman's clay and then
be like oh it's nasty
you can put your [ __ ] out on the
internet and not expect people to call
nasty No yeah if you're talking about my
clip for that long I'm gonna show you
what you're talking about otherwise
you're just ignorant talking about my
[ __ ] you're talking about a tennis clay
it's out ten inches okay
well I thought it was funny does that
help that you tweeted it to me as I'm
saying your other words cuz you think
you use it all by its I'm a comedian but
no not what I said I thought what you
tweeted to me that you tweeted me your
clip was what's funny I thought you were
being fun you made a funny you did dump
for anything no I was showing you what
you're talking about but you can't just
go on her it was a joke like you can't
just use that guys because you can't
just use that you can just say nasty
things to people like it's a joke but if
I thought it was gross the picture
that's not what I think that's not my
issue you're talking about my clip for
30 minutes on the thing and then I do
tell I mean a sees what I do not think
the image of a ten-inch and gorgeous
[ __ ] is funny cuz I thought I tried we
all had it but you're talking about mine
specifically I don't know what you're
Clint looks like I've never seen sudden
your [ __ ] is not a 10-inch engorged clip
yes but it is gross if that's your
opinion
it is my pad I thought it was nasty as
well I'm transgender which is why I'm a
male because people I've known Michael
it was gross my whole life so there you
go full circle I mean not everybody I
mean clearly you have supporters on
there on your on the website that you
promote on Twitter what website the one
that you're always probably land on yeah
Julian calm 18 plays private snapchat
videos will blur that because I don't
think that we can promote that on this
my trishy land and not calm patreon yeah
be a member julieopp calm you can see my
gorgeous quick keep it in if you had it
bat and not the other
I'll leave it in but I will say that I
don't think I'm the worst you're kind of
the worst but that's okay what if I
think you're the worst okay a lot of
people think you're the worst oh just
you people love me bro you huh you had
like a 90% download on the trans video
that doesn't mean anything it mean it
sure does
what's it mean I mean it means that you
had a largely negative reaction on the
video doesn't mean I'm the worst well
being the worst is kind of an abstract
concept but I think I mean it's a it's a
personal belief that I think the people
who smash the dislike button thought you
were the worst I don't think so I
disagree we'll have to take a poll take
a full illa do you think I'm the worst
tell me the truth you could be honest I
don't think you're the worst to be
honest you just said that what the [ __ ]
you literally just said you're through I
think you're I don't think well who's
the worst like if we have a scale of the
worst like let's say Adolf Hitler is the
worst do you think I'm as bad as Adolf
Hitler well you haven't killed people I
don't think so no okay you think he's
worse than dogs yes you're more damaging
to women yeah that's awesome yeah you
are you're damaging to women that's it
you give like that message was awful
nothing either I don't know it's not it
pushes me to do better thank you if you
can all thank you I know oh thank you
you you're come on you're laying there
not to it oh my god you're the worst
you're just awful but that's fine that's
fine I mean you're not worse than Hitler
but alive you're the worst like the
worst living person
Hitler's passed away so we exclude him
yeah so of people who are alive Charles
Manson still alive nope he's dead oh he
is mm-hmm
who lost is alive but don't compare
yourself to killers I'm talking about as
a human being hasn't killed somebody
okay so works what about like
sexual predators okay okay
you're talking about people who are like
evil I just think you're the worst human
beings came about Weinstein okay I don't
I'm a fan of Lucy K so I'm worse than
him
uh what did he do oh he like jerked off
in front of women and soon for the door
so they couldn't escape and they weren't
about it no I kind of like mister I like
a role-playing I don't know the
situation so I'm not speaking roleplay
no no he was he would go into a room and
be like hey could I drag off in front of
you and then he would just whip it out
and start jerking okay I'm not defending
him I'm not gonna try independent saying
like when I was like there's a pizza
here when I've hooked up with people if
I was like sleeping I'd be like you can
[ __ ] me when I'm sleeping yeah but you
gave him okay well regardless that's
yeah
permission ahead of time but I don't
know the situation so I'm not defending
him yeah it's fine so let's talk about
that that pizza has taken a long time in
Domino's [ __ ] up who is that that's
Dan I want to know what I want to talk
to you about Dan because you all them
too
okay they're the worst Ethan you're fine
actually your people are even worse than
you because when you ask them to rape me
mm-hmm first of all that alone is why
you're harmful to women asking like guys
to rate me right because if I was just a
completely disgusting human being FS
actually an unattractive like not
good-looking person you would never ask
that to them you wouldn't be like right
this ugly [ __ ] absolutely you would ask
someone to Rhea it I would I don't I
don't see your point that you wouldn't
rate someone that you thought well I'm
gonna say I'm saying you're saying he
lied that he's more attracted to you
than whoa no I'm not saying that I'm
just saying like don't be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] if you're gonna rape me which in
the other people are like no no we're
not gonna like whatever you were pushing
him to do it that's why I'm saying like
he wouldn't the other guys like no we
can't and Ian says they never rated you
but Dan gave you a three I believe
yeah that's I'm saying the other two
never did but you were like pushing you
like rate her well a lot and it's like
you shouldn't do that to women that's my
fair enough but I do think okay you're
you're right I shouldn't I shouldn't
have done that
yeah that being said you did say you had
beef with Dan and he is here now do you
have anything you want to say to him
hold on dansgame the pizza we should
bring down in here we should confront in
okay with
I do think that there's a double
standard though because women I think
when you get an insert a sewing circle
with women they'll they'll talk shop
about guys like women or men you know
what I mean like well I see what you're
saying but at the same time it's like
yeah but not on podcast I'm not going on
a podcast and be like let me rate you
you know what I mean I mean I do it back
to you because you do it to me by I mean
that's more like how do you rape me
on a scale of one to ten then as revenge
no I think the worst human yeah but on a
scale of attraction ten no you don't
plant your hundreds on my type I can't
say no front I know you're a 10 mm
that's confusing yeah I'm confused by
that I've never been ready to ten ELA
yard what would you rate them but you
wanted me to do just give me a ten yeah
I think your were you would you Whitney
would you
I deserve you oh god yeah you're a
thumbin so let me ask you this if either
if ela took your advice and moved on
would you make a move on me yes oh that
way you were trying to do the whole time
I truly do think you deserve better
I didn't know but if I'm a 10 what's
better than 10 has a pooper set for the
record I did not know you were actually
had a kid I thought that was a troll to
be honest so I'm I know I literally
thought that was like a we literally
have a child that's half me and know
that a newborn baby are you a nerd
Church I'm not a liar I'm not a
trickster I'm out of control you know
they say you know there's a great quote
that may resonate with you
they say we see the world not as it is
but as we are do you know what I'm
saying
no you see me as a troll and a trickster
nothing's true right you see me as that
way because you see through your own
lens you yourself are only seeing your
own kind of shadow being cast on the
work I don't think about anyone but you
guys but I don't think anyone else
thinks said about us I think so look at
right imagine be I do all the time there
Mary thing your siblings like that it's
a joke no imaginarily
though being so like what's the word
being so apprehensive and so distrustful
that you'd think we would fake having a
child together yeah because you guys
that video obviously couldn't have been
real the video you did about me there's
no way any of that was truthful or
anything like that there's no way like
the I just think you guys troll
everything like to the mobile scooter
like all that stray I think that's all
trolls egg I thought it was a goof there
was no way at how I thought that having
a baby so you think I'm a 10 what about
me is a 10 I'd like to know everything
your face your body your voice I have a
tiny penis is that a problem I love that
that makes it even hotter I do love tiny
penis is I love like shaming um oh you
oh so you like doing like a body
degradation there but I like little
penises if it's a I bet yours is 5 5
inches and I love that's my favorite I
probably could even get it you're such a
liar it's fine I know it is I know it is
I'm so good at that so you're a fan of
the Howard Stern Show right bringing the
pizza please I'm hungry and you have no
problem with how they Howard is very
womanizing cuz they very very very hard
language towards women yeah asked a
woman to write herself on the phone and
if she's a little overweight he's like
oh you're fine yeah that's like old
Howard which I totally agree you know
that's today
no I listen all the time I love Howard
Stern and here's the thing like bring in
the pizza sorry I was yelling at - it's
different it's different cuz also Howard
it's funny so it's different I'm not
yeah so you want a got guy who's not
funny yeah I like it not funny look I
like guys you think they're funny but
they're not I see when you know that I
have a large supporter of a fan base
that thinks I'm funny I don't know if
they think you're funny I think I think
you're interesting I think you're
interesting okay
well I'll take that I mean I guess I'll
take whatever it takes but I do think
that I mean generally speaking comedy I
mean the Instagram versus reality again
you're at sea you're trolling you don't
believe that
you're passing your own show on the
world don't leave what people don't
think I'm funny I know I read the
comments cuz even like other people like
Dan are you [ __ ] with me where's the
pizza oh I thought someone said you were
getting the pizza guy was lost he'll be
here I want to do that to you hmm
all right let's move let's move on we're
we're talking in circles here I want to
ask you quite other questions okay let's
move on what do we got here you I mean
I'm interested a little bit I think
you're interesting as well you're I
think you're no there's no there's no
there's not I promise you you did I did
notice that in your videos when you talk
about me she's winking at me and moving
her shoulders in no way that do you
think that's appropriate in front of my
wife doing anything he's literally lying
right now now who's the liar now and you
saw it anyways I want to [ __ ] with ela I
do think yours here by the way thank you
green and quickly fast and then I do
think you're interesting persons I want
to ask you some question won't get to
know you a little bit about why you are
who you are you came to LA where'd you
come to LA from Illinois but my dad
lived in LA so I was go back and forth a
lot and did you always want to be in
show business or yeah you did no Dan do
you want to join us and talk with Chris
Oh Mike
yeah bucket of ranch couple five further
back I don't love ranch but I'll do it
for this show as a gay man I would
expect you to enjoy that oh my god that
comas different than ranch [ __ ] you Dan
you did rate her a three so let's not
act like he didn't do anything that was
so you were is it true that you're an
escort at one point and so tell me about
that I mean one web would point I get
the pizza by myself because I'm fat is
that why okay you can I mean
money that was the timing of it I think
if we were funnier I could accept yeah
okay if I'm funnier does my rating go
down yeah as like on a connection level
yeah I'm not to work i luck bang like
guess that much pain yeah I'm so excited
let's just talk about my bang let's not
try to act like I love escorting why is
someone offering image me because I'll
do it not in this room in general do you
know somebody I'm bad what are you
ringing um I used to be cheap like I
think I was like $800 and I hear how
much for just like like what's the on
the menu well escorting is just
companionship you have to do anything
you can just hang out with someone but I
can change the gym or you can choose to
do more if you want to but that's not
what you're getting paid for legally I
see I see what you're saying okay you
know I mean yeah I know it so just $100
for a night I'll hang out with you how
wait what's your name Zach yes
what was your rate way on a scale of 1
to 10 of attractiveness no just like
just bias I have a boyfriend
she's getting married I'm getting
married I am engaged to so you can ask
Mike right now be honest
6 Wow oh wait nice are you serious are
you being nice I know I know you think
I'm attractive because no [ __ ] I give
you actually thought I was an ugly human
being like if you thought I was just the
nastiest human on earth you wouldn't
even say anything
if you truly thought that I know you I
know guys like you I think I like you
that like you're just so ugly and
disgusting but you would never you bet
are you being nice with it 6 like I know
that so I don't want to be rude but I
would rather drag my dick through a
field of glass I love his jokes don't
you know you see it's funny you're right
that's why you talk about my [ __ ] all
the time and Belle Duffy and all those
people whoa
you're low keeper if it's fine it's okay
I dated lots of pervs like it's fine
mouths word more superb it's fine Zac
can I read what you just row
Zach changed his rating he said you're
four he said that because of you you're
the boss and so he's like okay now I
gotta be unlike he's a psychic she's
gonna let me ask you about MOOC bank
what is it I don't hey no canned
laughter for her don't laugh at her
jokes people I have questions now we're
like eating and talking you know what
how did you get into to MOOC Bing what
is MOOC bang I was the first MOOC winger
look that up were you really so is it
like a Korean thing yeah okay so yeah I
saw it on like Korean internet like you
can go out like there's the dark web for
weird things like killing people but
then there's like a dark web for people
who like how like eating fetishes and
stuff like that so I used to go on like
and look for people who were eating and
it was a whole thing in Korean why why
do you want to watch people that you
didn't really because I noticed when
you're doing the MOOC bang you and
everybody there's lots of licking and
sucking and smacking is that I've always
thought it was like a fetish but is it
not yeah it's a little bit but I think
it's more mainstream now because people
like the talking and stuff with it and
but it is it's like for me it's a fetish
like I like watching people you get off
on it yeah that's what I always
suspected but what I found in the comics
was a lot of females who were just like
oh I wish I could eat that I think
that's become a thing now because people
don't fetishize it so fetishizing food
is like eating it crazy and sloppy and
messy like that's like a fetish version
now people are just doing like a normal
me like they're just eating but wait I
eat a lot you can or you can't like I
haven't been eating a lot lately in my
mukbangs so I think people do it now to
like for some reason for some people
it's like they don't get hungry because
they're watching someone else eat what
is mukbang then it's just eating in the
camera
essentially it's supposed to be lots of
food but yeah it's a lot right now
so I all right are you in to see food
mukbangs because I noticed I don't I
find this to be just unbelievably boring
you've seen this video yes this is a
eating with Q she's got a 15 pound
lobster quod she just going at it this
doesn't do it for me
but I get why people like it do not like
seafood I think right I won't feel of
life with a huge amount
we did together our union to your
friends with the legendaries we're
together I'm a mukbang your collab shot
only my singers shout-out to them of
course yeah yeah we love well have you
ever pooped after a mukbang really mom
just once
I'm not a puker by nature but I peed one
time just from overeating I ate a squid
it was live did y-yeah where was that
was that filmed I filmed it I never
uploaded it because I think you can get
in trouble for uploading you ate a lot
yeah
why did you eat live well it's a
delicacy over in like I don't wanna get
this wrong either probably Japan or
China somewhere cuz I got it from
overseas and I don't think you're
supposed to get a no big was it no
definitely not
that's bad in every so this was a long
time so I just never uploaded it and
I've incriminate myself but how big was
it like the size of this cut maybe but
the tentacles you know we're like
hanging down like that and so where did
you eat at first if it was alive like
where do you start I didn't know it was
alive so I think it's up on YouTube
there's some people who do this over
wherever it's legal to do this they eat
the live squid it like just moves so I
don't know if it's necessary alive or it
just moves well how did it arrive to you
in like a little like aquarium like a
little like fish bag thing overseas in a
fish but anyway to go pick it up at the
airport it's like getting a dog over
starts yeah how much what was it
expensive
no like a couple thousand dollars I
guess I don't know I mean I'm you so so
it didn't resist a lot just moved a
little bit when you ate it yeah and then
but it still was moving inside my
stomach and how did it taste
mmm I didn't taste like anything to me
the squid I got is like a transparent
squid so just didn't taste like anything
mmm was a while ago I mean I see you
like cool fishes as a kid I said like
swallow goldfish
so I don't think you're supposed to do
that either but I would just eat the
fish out of the bowl
why would you do that I don't know I
thought it was honestly food I was young
I was like 5 mm yeah and um and and what
are you I'm just curious when you eat a
lot because I saw you for example when
you did recently was like pizza and
chick-fil-a and so do you have like wild
bowel movements after you do the nook
things other podcast and it got caught
because it was such a gross topic
well please do anything gross yet but
you've got to have like crazy don't
that's the thing and people talk about
this and they think it maybe it's
another lied you want to come measure my
bowels every day you can I definitely
don't but it's just it's like the law of
physics right what comes in what's must
go out I know there's something
literally wrong with my body I'm not I
just eat a lot yeah maybe just used to
it yeah that's why I have a gut because
all my food stays there it doesn't
adjust all right well enough with the
questions
so guys this is a part of the show where
it's pretty much you know it's just
gonna be a [ __ ] show from here don't
expect anything but what I mean is
there's gonna be lots of chewing and
eating I'm here for pizzanel so here's
what I want to do with you let's take a
slice my kind of move bang I like just
the tips of the piece I don't ever get
the crust I just eat like the tips Wow
okay you don't even get close to the
crust it is for you too and this for the
podcast yeah he's not gonna end up on
like a porn site or anything right
unless it's yours a tree a tree will
just come out of their mouths yeah but I
mean I'm not taking off my clothes I'm
just eating pizza that's hot that's the
hottest so you don't take off the
clothes I don't I don't eat it in okay
like oh my god really
it's Moo ping okay gonna flash it
everywhere okay I mean it's not as
gnarly as I did why did you do both
sides that's hard to eat it's moot bang
bang oh my gosh and then what do we do
so we just we hit it and that's the rest
of this that's I mean yeah Oh gross and
the ranch is awful Ian's got ranch light
oh I have to eat it though ain't got my
transfer while I while I am how I think
of wouldn't help them I've swallowed it
no growing of a bugs why
about really hmm don't you think or no I
know you think I'm the worst but I
actually really like you I don't take
your word I don't need them I don't
think anyone's divorce except like
Donald Trump really we hate him here um
okay well thank you because actually I
genuinely like you yeah I don't know I
was looking at you and I meant a you
yeah so I genuinely like you and I'm
glad you had a real baby I didn't know
this I'm sorry I do apologize for all
the baby comments cuz I thought it was
fake so my apologies he's very real so
magnets are you're lucky
mmm why not I had chlamydia twice and it
damaged my tubes so what I got the hsg
test to see if I was fertile I was
blocked my tubes are scarred did you
catch chlamydia in the line of duty or
personal life I would say in the line of
duty I blame their personal boyfriend at
the time when during work hmm no but you
were using protection right no oh that's
why I stopped Wow yeah they don't want
to have condoms yeah what really mm-hmm
I just got an STD test if you want to
see it though if you want to see the
Apple I mean I believe I'm not okay I
feel like I need to prove everything now
not everything like my resuits yeah I
have the receipt I'm not fun yeah yeah
scary yeah I was really scary at the
time I did it bother me it's like
whatever but now it's scary that's yeah
I guess yeah but I don't love condoms
but you should wear them but they're not
great well I'm in in your line of work I
would assume well I don't do that it
would be mandatory no they don't want to
do it you mean David David clients I
would think that they would want it to
evoke that's how nasty guys are that's
how nasty I can't straight men are there
just to get anything you want always
straight I don't understand do you think
that you hate men because of your
previous experience working in that
profession did you always hate straight
men do you hate your father no I love my
father why do you think you hate
straight men there does awful
they're the worst in general so
everybody I just looped you in there
because you're in that category I'm just
trying to understand cuz I don't think
all women hate straight man no just me I
thought surely you must
for a reason huh must be that I just
don't like them there's certain people
you just don't like and straight men are
my enemy I guess you're racist against a
man I don't know that's racist that's
maybe have you had bad experiences
though um yeah I think so
and I hate all of them like I hate every
single straight man that's been in my
life so maybe maybe there is some
background to that have you been cheated
on lied to yeah bad relationships all of
them maybe maybe I do maybe there is
something to that then I don't know yeah
everyone cheats on me everyone's awful
and the worst and straight people love
to hit like I used to get like beat the
[ __ ] out of him something that like we
should beat the [ __ ] on me when I was
like my first like three relationship
yeah my person
like three years in LA everyone like I
usually just get like every night with
like a [ __ ] like boxing match ends up
but a gate man I've never liked that
lesbians have never been like that with
me
so I guess I just hate straight them and
you know what I can't move on hit anyone
yeah I would say that my experience is
with that but yeah no I thought thought
why I hate the majority I assume most
people don't beat the [ __ ] out this
clear I mean clearly not all men are
violent I mean like that yeah but some
are and a lot our cheaters a lot are a
lot of pervert but I think of underage
girls like yeah so do you
are you ever afraid that it might be the
your choices drive these bad characters
into your life my choice is how and men
the men you're attracted to I feel like
I do everybody like anybody wants to
date me I'll date them so I feel like I
don't I'm not picky at his date whoever
wants to date me hmm so maybe the image
you put out to the world attracts the
wrong kind of guy I've heard that oh my
god this is like therapy no not so deep
you are like a dad even though you're
only 34 you're like a 14 I am a bad oh
yeah you're not the worst
I actually oh my god I kind of like love
you think what a cry like I honestly
feel like crying but he thought about
that before
well cause like you're asking me
questions about me and my relationships
I mean well I'm curious why you hate
straight man I mean there's clearly a
reason you know I just like love you
I find it interesting that just some
basic interest in your us person can
react such emotional response okay okay
but but I think I find that yeah I mean
I can see why we gotta get you uh we got
to get you a a good man in your life who
is this day you marry yeah tell me about
[Laughter]
why that's a bad sign ready to be
private okay well tell me about him he
is he's just really great I just met him
like about a month ago he just kind of
came you meet him online uh-huh
[Music]
just had my I can't really delve into it
too much but just local media not
necessarily no email no dating app I
can't talk about it I can't talk about
how we met cuz he'll get mad at like
people know yeah is he a public figure
yes okay he's a public figure you guys
are the world guys had a whirlwind
romance
but why get married right away so fast
it's pretty fat is it real I don't know
I didn't ask him but I'm sure it's not a
big he makes money yeah then it's not
real okay well maybe he does make money
I don't know much about him
I really don't does it matter to you if
we got makes money no no no I like guys
that are broke actually when my last
boyfriend my last boyfriend I met him
and he was broke as [ __ ] and then he
start making money and he left me hmm
happens all the time so I prefer them
broke cuz they're they're less likely to
look for in your mind better options
yeah because they're like they're more
humble oh [ __ ] once they get money he's
like okay I'm gonna go [ __ ] a 17 year
old what p.m. model okay good luck with
that cuz she was 18 I don't know
whatever the [ __ ] she was I can see I
can I can see that you've had a lot of
negative I'm sorry oh my god so my
dollars at him thank you for every nice
I would really like you okay and you I
love you but what how what can we do
about that you guys are good for each
other you are I'm sorry you guys are
just good for each other you're just
good people I'm watching about a baby
I'm glad you were black I've been
together for like 12 years
I know it's amazing it's beautiful I'm
sorry if you found the right guy who
you're well you're engaged to a straight
man yeah so how does that jive with you
identifying as a gay man that's fine you
can be straight does he know you're gay
man mmm yeah he's cool with you yeah of
course they seen my videos my videos are
out there right that's probably I mean
presumably he came to you so this guy is
a public figure but he doesn't have
money ah not like he's not ballin he's
not rich he's not a millionaire
maybe but what's a millionaire you know
I'm a millionaire I don't have money you
know what I mean
yeah there's a difference between you
know 1 million and 1020 million
yeah you're a millionaire good for you
so just spend my money like a crazy
person so what's it really mean at the
other day what do you waste your money
on the most um shopping my music videos
are like $100,000 apiece those are
really my little production you have to
say I kinda I've been doing like two a
month so I need to like go down on that
but and you I've noticed you that you're
touring a lot is it your music there you
go yeah it's over now but yeah just
finish till you make money from that
yeah I'm really good at making money
I've always had been whether it's like
hooking stripping now it's like patreon
- or music you have been on like every
single show possible yeah I go I love I
like I like I like yeah I don't know oh
my god I think I just like attention I
think I think I honestly just like
attention so honestly I wanted to come
on this podcast forever and look at that
my trolling landed me here on this
podcast so yes it did I mean and you
know look when we when we talk about you
people like to watch oh I don't know I
like you know what I do this is how
psycho and like narcissistic I am I like
to go to when people make videos about
me and talk about me and use me as a
thumbnail I can compare those views to
their other videos I'm like let's see of
my video with me and then what did you
find when when compared yeah I got more
than the Bobby Lee interview which I'm
shocked
and I feel like Bobby Lee's a big deal
he is he's a big yeah I'm saying you're
you're an interesting person I think I
think and I think this episode's gonna
do very well as well I think we're gonna
join and people are going to click I am
NOT promoting this that's fine we don't
need the promo thank you for having me
on the promo ah well I hope that we be
friends in real life yeah yeah or some
prime number I've always been I've
always considered our jousting as as
friendly okay
and I've always figured you probably
think of it I mean especially recently
yeah when you make video and I make a
video than you it's fun and I was and I
always get excited when you're spying on
my podcast but now it's over now we're
friends and now I like if you talk about
me again I swear now I know where you
work remember well I feel I feel like
this was the perfect conclusion because
I couldn't really draw it out anymore
people were being or we're already gonna
be like Ethan enough videos about Trisha
this is like we get to milk it one last
time I'm so tired of you talking about
her - I love her - like you know we all
know spit spit your back a lot of
emotions for you yeah actually I don't
know why this is like a torture house
everything
so should we wrap it up is this how you
experience like 100% this and then only
got it from the worst yeah that's kind
of me maybe there's something wrong with
me
I go to DBT classes where's my camera
it's right here I go to DBT classes okay
I get it under control
I'd be fine for borderline for
borderline percentage sort a lot of
people think I have BPD and I go to DPT
for its group therapy I make the skills
I do the lessons been going since May
8th what's up there's a borderline
personality or me I'm thinking of
anti-social what does borderline
personalities I don't know people will
diagnose me with it so I don't know
my therapist is tell me to go to these
DBT classes so I maybe he thinks because
I asked them I said tell me do I have up
my my bipolar or some [ __ ] and he's like
well everyone has traits of like
personality disorders he goes you have
like traits of borderline protected
medical mental illness there's nothing
wrong with it love mental illness talk
about all the time we love metal
I love it-it's my I love you fed mental
and it's all my boyfriend's I've been
bipolar so it's fine what doli like
they're functioning so well let's
I think we're reached the National
conclusion do we have any last words I'm
just gonna continue eating pizza what is
that do you suppose
it's your fitting window by the way I
know feeling window yeah I called my
feeding window though cuz it's funny
here but I just I actually just started
I think I'm doing really well I feel
like at night you are actually doing
well which I'm sad to say because I
don't like the feeling windows don't
lose you much weight though but honestly
I do things like I wasn't being [ __ ]
you do look like a tent like if you lose
too much weight then you're gonna be
like mm-hmm
you know I I disagree for health it's
good for health for sure be healthy you
look fat guys know I like well I don't I
got been with that guys like you're a
like a little a little extra cuz it's
awful I don't I never I don't want him
to be skinny
no I don't want him to be skinny you
know what me skinny so no just be
healthier yeah I got that you're very
thin but very pretty I don't know if
it's offensive I don't know if you can
call them people within anymore I think
it's a compliment I don't care you look
good I mean I don't give a [ __ ] I'm like
you're so lucky but I know you're not
supposed to say that any more than you
can't you can't call people thin that's
the problem I get it I get it I do but
for me it's not a compliment sounds like
you look skinny oh my god so I get it
and I got to readjust myself yeah I'm
educating myself what that's the problem
that I don't like everyone being so
sensitive it's like oh you don't know
I've I eat this pizza by myself
yeah you are did you eat anything no
just one bite did you eat any from this
bag no but I'm almost I had half of my
own so did I really eat all that cuz I
can eat this like you can see all I ate
give me that slice after him don't this
I love watching you eat it's so good is
that why you're with him because of how
I eat no I
so good like you just eat you just don't
get a lot of noises I know I don't like
you don't know I like that you eat
you're you're talented because you can
eat and talk at the same time and it's
so it's so amazing audience likes it no
I love I warned them at this point yeah
this is amazing
Wow I love you you're really cool I'm so
excited
Wow I've even a whole pizza oh [ __ ]
Philip DeFranco can I just say that you
wanna [ __ ] what do you do he took your
side just because he's your used a fan
of you I don't kiss you on the Instagram
personality thing I'm right everyone
took my side nobody took your side
everyone's like [ __ ] him you can't talk
to a woman like that like you can't do
whatever so [ __ ] Philip DeFranco knees
like I'm a fan of your podcast oh [ __ ]
you
everybody took my side nobody did look
nobody did be more on my side with that
oh my god you're alright let's wrap it
up any comments from backstage anything
are we all done yeah we're starting the
music oh we got the music so there's no
turning back
how long's episode in doubt move thank
you for the record yeah I'm moving the
[ __ ] at it that means that he has some
sort of a problem you didn't even notice
eating a whole pie it's a little bit of
a problem or at lack of awareness I
think I think in general not full I need
to find them like that literally
everybody I've been with - they just
don't eat nobody eats everyone my last
boyfriend Fasching me all the time
that's always a big issue I let him eat
a video call like my boyfriend family
why would it I mean like why would you
start dating you a few thoughts exactly
there's videos of him being like um how
many Nuggets are you eating um what like
there's a whole thing I don't think you
care I don't think he didn't care about
you being fat I think he just liked
demeaning you hmm I think you're right
that's the issue right there and [ __ ]
that guy we're done yeah Jason
oh that's do you want to bring him up
but you said it you said [ __ ] that guy
so well yeah if you say there's a whole
bunch of videos look that up there's all
new videos of him like making fun of how
what I eat and how I eat
I mean he's not that skinny now yes he
lost a bunch of weight okay I don't know
him at all I have no problem with them
should I I dunno I see your mortal enemy
song is nearing the hen base and I
apologize yeah it's still wrong it's
very we always have a problem ending the
show I just want to apologize station -
I don't know I don't want you I don't
not taking sides
you just said [ __ ] that guy because you
like it just sound like Jimmy me you
given what you've said I'm sure here's a
different no it's out there online has a
different angle to the story than you so
I don't I'm not taking sides
I don't care me [ __ ] that guy I don't
know given what you said then yeah [ __ ]
that guy but I'm sure if he was here he
would be like oh whoa oh I should taken
out of context you would say that no
it's on lots of videos well then [ __ ]
thank you what do we do just wrap it up
alright guys thank you for watching was
today today's Friday right yeah thank
you guys for watching doing anything
planned next week we have I think a
guess next Friday who we got I'm
checking right now no that's the week
after just in case okay we have nothing
planned yeah but you guys like that
we'll be making two podcasts about
Tricia pack the week next week so thank
you guys for watching I hope you have a
fantastic weekend and wish you all the
very very best and uh god bless here uh
I'm gonna
can I eat your slice no but I'm Luke
thinking it's my feeding window okay
thank you guys my good happy
[Music]